[Music]
why is it that the Muslims and if they
are peaceful and they're calling and
saying they're peaceful Muslims they
simply want to imprison repentant
terrorists and they want to release
Guantanamo Bay that's the question I
asked from all the Liberals and the
Muslims who condemn me for speaking out
Against Terror if terrorism destroyed my
family
[Music]
we will kill all the infidels one by one
Brothers come on come on yeah
[Music]
we will kill all the infidels one by one
hello we made a sweet I would like to
share with you would you please access
this
what is it
it's so sweet
oh
[Music]
oh yeah
hi hi when did it come from vacation
live uh well I have some of your
important documents what sort of
document I'll wait for some time I'll
get it for you
uh these are your newspapers and this is
the career which my brother collected
and kept for you
this is also your letter my brother kept
for you
thank you thank you
okay okay
hey oh Robert Spencer how are you
I just want you to know what made you to
do this for me well coming for snacks
I'll explain you it's nice yep
Brothers Let's welcome our never rub
expensive
um
brother Robert please have some juice
[Music]
let's have some snacks
brother Robert you wanted to know why we
did this for you it's simple it is
mentioned in a religion Islam to be good
to your neighbors and Prophet Muhammad
peace be upon him said that a person a
Muslim cannot be a Muslim unless a lot
for others vanilla for himself oh and
that's the reason I made a sweet for you
and I got for you and also Prophet
Muhammad
said whenever you make abroad add some
water to it and present it to your
neighbor
yeah in continuation to that Prophet
Muhammad May Allah's mercy be upon him
also said a Muslim is not a Muslim by
whose Hand by whose conduct his
neighbors are not safe
well I want to learn more about your
religion and your profit
best book on the face of the Earth about
Prophet Muhammad peace be upon it
because Quran and the best book to know
what Islam means
is put on so it's my pleasure to give
you the Holy Quran you read it you'll
understand the real Islamic
is
[Music]
I am
foreign
[Music]
which means
to submit your will to almighty God
[Music]
oh Robert Spencer how are you I'm fine
thank you I just want to say one thing
yeah I research on your religion
and I want them resistance really yeah
[Music]
foreign